All right. Ami Mac, thank you
for being on my show.
How are you?
I'm doing well.
How are you, Michael?
I am doing just fine.
So, you work [--]
from the Bay Area, right?
But you actually, have of something
very very relevant to what's happening today.
And you're the director
of Translational Medicine
at the Genome Center
within Stanford Medicine, right?
Did I get that right?
That's correct.
The Stanford Genome Technology Center.
Okay. So, what is that mean?
What does that mean, that you're leading
the translational medicine?
Sure. So, first of all,
thanks for having me on this show.
Of course.
You're doing a great job.
This is wonderful and very exciting.
And so, at Stanford, your Alma Mater,
the Stanford Genome Technology Center
is a center where we use genetics,
microbiology, lots of different technology,
work with engineering.
And it's a multi-disciplinary group
that really is involve with lots of innovation,
and new product development used to study
all sorts of
different healthcare-related problems
as well as biotech type of problems.
So, I talked with Dr. Ryan Davis,
and he was one of the leaders
in the looking at the human genome.
Wow. Okay, that's amazing.
Actually, your life story is very unique.
And I think, that's what I want us to start.
Because you're starting out
as a patient yourself.
So, you're a swimmer, exercise enthusiast
suffering a chronic disease
of lower back pain. Is that right?
Yeah. Well, lower back pain
was just part of my story.
To be quite honest,
this has been about a 20-year journey.
And so, the reason
translational medicine is so important to me
is because, it really is a field in which
you have to understand the patients
and what their needs are.
You have to understand
what researchers are looking for and doing
And then you have to be able to take
all of those things together.
Bridge physicians, researchers,
and patients' needs,
and come out with the most strategic way
to get to a goal.
And so, really understanding
what the needs of the various stakeholders
that are involve in.
For example, designing a diagnostic test,
or learning how to use yeast
for all new purposes.
Science can be done often times
in a way that is very, a nuance.
And so, being able to guide researchers
to say, this is actually what's relevant
and this is what the patient's need,
is really where I fit in.
Okay. But you know,
you have the unique position of,
transitioning from patient
that you think, 20-year journey
you underwent a massive surgery.
And you know you can empathize
with the path that a lot of people
in similar situations,
not necessarily the same disease per se,
but different situations are facing,
and then, you are transitioning
to being a physician.
And now, you are acting as a researcher
and trying to innovate
past what we know today, right?
That's right.
So, about 20 years ago,
I had mononucleosis.
Which is a very common viral infection,
Epstein-Barr virus.
95% of the population actually has it.
But, somehow, for some reason
in my immune system,
that virus triggered something
and caused immunodeficiency.
And therefore,
I became more and more sick.
Ultimately, I was diagnosed
with the condition called
chronic fatigue syndrome,
which is now currently named
myalgic encephalomyelitis.
I understood the first one.
The second one, I didn't understand.
I admit it's a mouthful.
We call it ME for short.
And you may have heard a little bit about it
because now, with covid-19,
what we're finding is, with SARS patients,
covid-19 patients,
patients who have all sorts of
other communicable diseases,
many of them end up with this
unrelenting fatigue, as well as other problems.
Dizziness, brain fog, difficulty thinking.
And so, what we're doing
at the Stanford Genome Technology Center,
is we have heavily put
many of the resources
towards trying to come up
with the diagnostic test for this illness,
and solving the illness.
And looking at its molecular underpinning.
Crazy. You know,
that's exactly why I love this show so much.
Because, we're preparing to do
this episode together,
And now that I got an email from this thing,
like, "Michael, just FYI, we're working on
on this crazy development
that's happening with covid.
And we're the front.
And then, I'm so excited to talk to you
about that, what is it like
being now on the forefront,
and discovering with the world,
but a little bit before the world,
how this unbelievable pandemic
is taking its shape?
Like really really to make sense of
all the confusion there.
Well, to be honest,
at times it can be frustrating.
Because we see things ahead of time.
And, as scientist, researchers,
and physicians, we need to prove
certain things using research,
however, based on prior viruses
we can have some idea
of what is in store
and have some predictions.
I was speaking with my colleague
and boss, Dr. Ryan Davis,
about two years ago,
and we had talked about how one day,
there will be a global pandemic of this nature.
And it's really quite astonishing
that this is actually happening now.
So, to be doing the work that we're doing,
it's very exciting.
And the way that I look at it is,
there's so many things
from a scientific perspective
that we need to still learn.
But to be able to be
right at the leading edge of discovery,
is so so exciting.
And what i really would love people to know
is that, I had an illness.
I went to medical school.
I went to residency.
I went to fellowship training.
Practice as a physician.
Ended up here.
Did some work with healthcare and technology,
and really dove deep a long time ago
into app development.
And how we can use mobile applications
to really understand
what's happening to humans.
And at this point now,
we have wearables that can plug-in to apps.
We have all sorts of really cool
innovative techniques to gather data,
so that we can tell patient's stories
and connect it to the research.
Because often times we do all this
really great molecular
and genetic tests and whatnot.
But what we're trying to do
is get real time data from people.
And make sure that that's clean,
and precise data.
And that's a huge challenge.
But somebody's got to do it, right?
100%. 100%.
So, talk to me a little bit about
this journey of yours, as a researcher.
Coming in as somebody,
a young entrepreneur, software engineering,
I don't get exposed too much to biotech
and the work with genomes,
and understanding the human body
the way that you do,
how do even get to start in this field?
And what's your day to day like?
Oh, that's a great question.
So, my day to day is very different.
I don't have a typical day.
And what I've asked
to accomplish in the center varies,
depending on which team I'm working with.
Right.
For example, right now,
I'm working on a project where
we are developing an app
So that we can continue to collect data
from patients who have covid-19,
to see what percentage of patients
end up developing
this chronic long-standing condition.
So, recently, Chris Cuomo on CNN,
stated that he also has this condition.
And Anthony Fauci has also talks
about how so many people
are ending up with long standing
long term debilitating issues
as a result of covid.
And so, for me, this has been my life's work.
And I'm so passionate about it
because I was one of those people
who is never supposed to make it.
I was one of those people
who was too sick to finish medical school.
Or too ill to do residency.
And for me, finally, doing my own research
and figuring out what was going on
and being able to maneuver healthcare,
because as a physician, I understood
how the healthcare system work.
For me, that's a great story, personally.
But, what I'm concerns about is
what about the people who don't know
how to navigate the healthcare system?
How do we plug them in?
And then, how do we get people,
like you Michael, to come and help us
process through all these data,
use artificial intelligence to make sense of
the voluminous amount of data
that we're gathering.
And to really help find answers
and clusters, and uncover
a lot of problems that we find.
Especially the immune system.
The immune system is
extremely interesting.
And, we know things, but there's a lot
that we don't know.
And we need people to help us
from the data side.
We need people to help us
from the technology and wearable side.
We need fun, engaging apps.
We need to find that with the researchers.
I think that's incredible.
I'm actually very close to a startup
back in Tel Aviv called, Immunai.
They just recently came out
of stealth mode, and they're trying to use
artificial intelligence to uncover
the immune system.
And to help do research on that front.
But then, coming in as a researcher,
how do you, as a doctor now
think about this integration
with engineering and artificial intelligence?
Because I'm assuming that most doctors
in your position, don't necessarily have
the technological expertise of years
of dealing with data,
and all of a sudden, you understand that
in order to really make sense
of the research you're doing,
you're gonna need support from people
who have no idea about what you're doing
but they are experts in artificial intelligence
and you have to find this
in this weird combination, right?
Yeah. Yeah.
So, first of all, I have an amazing father
who is an engineer
and computer scientist himself.
So, being around a lot
of computer science people growing up,
I recognize the need for technology
to really help us solve problems.
So, he was in supply chain management.
So, I was able to apply
his supply chain management theory
to how to run the practice fluidly.
I think that I'm fortunate
and that I work with such amazing,
brilliant researchers.
I'm learning every single day.
So, how I ended up here to be quite honest,
I let life guide me.
It was quite serendipitous.
I had done genetic research in undergrad
and I was thinking about doing an MD-PhD.
but they didn't have an MD-PhD program
at the time.
So, I just did my MD.
But unfortunately, I became ill.
And so, I got frustrated.
I've been both medical student
and a patient.
So, afterwards, I left medicine.
And I work in an internet startup company.
And then, I also,
so, we were doing UI/UX
before UI/UX ever even existed.
When are we talking about?
What year is this?
This was 2004.
Wow.
Right.
Wait. But that startup,
it was in the medical space, right?
No, actually, it was completely different.
Completely different.
It was a language learning company
called Mango Languages.
And it's still in existence.
And they're doing wonderfully.
But I always wondered, where all of this
different experiences I had,
when it will all come together.
and interestingly then, I was able UI/UX
and what I learned about that
to creating mobile healthcare apps.
I work with UPMC,
University of Pittsburgh Medical Center
and Harvard, and we have done
a lot of work on creating an app
and I've done some advising in the past.
So, being able to integrate
just these various experiences,
if there's one thing I would say to people,
is don't be afraid to try something new.
Because the convergence of learnings
from different fields,
is really where innovation comes from.
It really teaches you to think differently.
And I encouraged people,
there's a lot of times, students will say to me,
"Oh my gosh, I wanna
take time off of school."
"But my parents don't want me to."
And I'll sit down
and talk to the parents and say,
"You know what? That experience,
one day, will really serve your son
or daughter really well."
So, don't be afraid to try new things.
Because one day, just like in my life now,
everything manages to make sense,
and come together.
And all of a sudden now,
you're dealing with the same disease
that you had to deal with for 20 years.
But now, you're dealing with it
from a research perspective.
And what are the implications
and how to help others through it.
But Ami, then talk to me a little bit about
this teaching style and mentorship.
You're alluding to that.
And right before our call,
you mentioned to me that
that is one of the things
that you're really passionate about.
So, what is teaching for you or mentorship
guiding others through their own journey?
Which you're mentioning is
very sometimes difficult to do
when you're getting a lot of pressure
from different sources,
and it's hard to navigate your own path.
So, to me, I was very fortunate.
I started my residency
and joined our academic association,
the Association of Academic Physiatrists.
And there, I was very inspired.
Because we have lots of physician leaders
that took all of us on.
And what I learned is,
you can never have enough mentors.
Because each mentor,
may have something different to offer.
One might be more interested in media affairs.
And another might be more interested
in technology. And there's so many
different things you can learn
from each one of them.
So, I always tell people,
don't be afraid to seek out
as many mentors as you can.
And for me, one day, when I'm gone
it's important to bring other people
into others who will be doers.
Other will be thinkers.
And you're excited about forging ahead.
We're living right now
in a very tumultuous time.
Tumultuousness doesn't mean that
we have to fade away.
It means, this is an opportunity
to really seek deeply what's in your soul
and pull that resilience out, and say,
"What can we do to make this better?"
Because there's always been times
in history where there's been scary things
that have gone on, whether a war,
this, that, or the other thing.
But it's really the people
who pulled themselves up and said,
"How do we fix this?"
That's really what pushes humanity forward.
I think one of the most common phrases
of Stanford Business School
is, don't waste a good crisis, right?
Yes.
I remember who coined it,
I think is was Churchill or something.
But I think it's very true.
And it's not just in the realm of
how to leverage economically
a crisis that's happening.
And that's a lot of where entrepreneurs
go to, but also, how do,
in terms of mentorship and teaching,
how do you take this time
of introspection and understand
what do you want to do.
And I have a lot of people that I speak to
that have been taking this time out
and re-evaluating what their priorities are.
Which you're forced to do when you're,
when all of a sudden you don't have
all of the experiences outside
that are noise, that don't allow you
to look internally, right?
Absolutely.
You bring up a really good point.
Breaks for self-reflection
are really important.
Because otherwise, you end up
having completely different path
than where you want to be.
And, we go in different directions.
Sure. Ami, what are you excited about?
What are really gets you up
in the morning and make's you
so passionately and glowing
throughout the day?
First of all, learning.
I also, still continue to have mentors.
So, every day, learning about
what we can do with healthcare technology,
all the research.
I mean, reading constantly.
Throwing myself into the work.
But what really excites me is,
this disease that I've suffered from
for 20 years, that has received
very little attention, very little funding.
Unfortunately, there's a pandemic.
But fortunately, we have the opportunity,
like you said, now, to study this,
and understand what's happening.
And it's too bad that it took
a global pandemic for us to be able to
seek out the answers
to what is happening inside of the body,
as people transition from getting a virus
and what happens long term.
But we have to grab it with both hands.
And so, for me, trying to let people
know what's happening
and get funding for this kind of work,
and speaking with the different researchers
and talking to the FDA
about how are gonna get things improved.
But what really grabs me is,
how we can leverage technology now
to answer questions
that we could never answer before.
There's so much data out there.
And so, we need technology
to be able to really parse through
all that information that's coming at us.
Yeah. I mean,
that's exactly where I think,
the world is headed right now, right?
We're seeing this bloom of understanding
that now we have to leverage data science
with the work of researchers and doctors
like yourself, to really make sense
of what's happening.
And I'm personally very very excited
to see where we're headed.
And what's gonna happen
the next few years.
I'm especially excited
to be a part of this transition
and get my own hands dirty
with a lot of this work.
Ami, before we leave, I have to ask you
the most important question.
Three words that you would use
to describe yourself.
Let's see.
Inquisitive.
Okay.
Fierce.
Fierce. What does that mean?
Fierce means,
seeing that something's challenging
and going for it anyway.
Okay.
So, I guess the next one would be,
Confident.
Confident that you will figure it out.
And resilient.
Inquisitive. Fierce. And confident.
I love that. I think, that's exactly
what it takes to do the work
that you're doing.
So, no surprises there.
Oh, thank you Michael.
No, no. This was great.
Thank you also for your generosity.
Thank you for your time.
This was just inspiring.
I'm personally, I think that,
I can't wait to get [--] to this world
and understand it better.
Because this is where the impact is
at the end. At the end,
it's literally savings lives
and helping people going through pain
live their lives better, healthier,
and in less pain.
And coming in from the data science,
I myself, I'm just excited to see this.
this harmony. I'm very excited.
One last thing I do want to
let everybody know, is that,
we estimate that 2.5 million Americans
have chronic fatigue syndrome
or myalgic encephalomyelitis.
And there's been less than $5 per patient
of NIH moneys that have been put
towards this.
Just to give you a little bit of background,
there's 950,000 of patients with HIV.
This is 75% of patients with this illness
are either home-bound or bed-bound.
So, it's [-] disability.
So, if you think about it,
about at least 10% of patients with SARS
developed this.
Now, if 10% of patients
with SARS to or covid-19 develop this,
we have a big problem on our hands.
So, we really have no choice,
but to really figure out what's going on.
Because perhaps, we can prevent things
from happening to other people,
that can destroy lives.
Unbelievable.
Ami, thank you very much for the inspiration.
Thank you, Michael.
Stay safe and stay healthy.
I look forward to talking again.
Take care. Bye bye.